I can't hear my inputs right now I only
put them there just for my own sake
here's where the real work begins what
calculations are we going to need to
have okay now you'll notice I'm doing
all of this kind of you know line by
line work before I put together you know
cells right and the design of each one
because I want to know all the things
I've got to fit into this before I draw
out where they going to fit if you're
like it's a bit like you know which to
use design first you know a car's body
it's outside body or all the things that
are going to fit into it hmm well you
probably want to design the things that
fit into a first like say the engine
right rather than oh we've designed the
outside body first and the engine we
designed after doesn't fit in and I
could see when some of you done your
spreadsheet you had yourselves there you
did start to lay it out and then as you
went through and did your calculations
Eddie you're like oh missing bits right
and it sort of grew off I you know went
on a different 90 degrees perpendicular
the page because we're trying to squeeze
it in because your engine was too big
for the body of your car ok so that's
why i doing all this first right ok now
i think i think i had ten one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
calculations ok now it wasn't like one
mark for every single calculation okay I
was giving a mug too okay do we identify
all the other inputs ok I gave a mark
two marks to the actual layer and if it
was logical ok so it's don't treat these
as like you had to get every single one
in order to get your ten bucks but
whatever you did have it had to be
accurate and had to cover all of the
basis that we mentioned earlier ok hello
now up one more thing when I describe
all of this stuff I'm going to describe
it without reference to any cells ok for
two reasons number one I don't have any
sales yet like I don't know what a 1 and
B 5 and all that I think are right but
number two every one of their dog had a
different completely you know separate
design and everything rearranged
differently so even if i gave you cells
here right it would be meaningless for
you're so
do instead is I'm going to describe each
cell right and this is the way you can
construct yours then when you put
together your desire and you've got your
you know you know which rose which rose
at which columns refer to what then you
can say all right this is going to be a
five this will be C seven all right now
the first thing I'm going to work out if
I want to work out where am I going to
end I'm gonna condone prophets prophets
who you tell me what kinds of things are
we going to need to know if we want
profits what is a profit yeah great see
you like um you buy something and then
you sell it to someone else you make a
profit right so the two things you need
to know our how much did you pay for it
in the first place that's a cost and
then how much did you sell it for
afterwards right so your sales price
okay so I want to go for sales first
right because it comes first so total
sales and each of these calculations is
different from you need you okay so for
every one of these calculations i'm
going to have one for year 2014 14 2015
and so on so total sales now where is
this relate to these are we going to
relate to what is it related soon hmm if
i want to think about what what I a
sales from one year to the next is I've
got my previous year's sales right I
know that from here ok I've got past
these sales records okay and I think
okay next year i think the total sales
will be now what other piece of
information do I need to put it with
pass your sales records plus or times
actually what what's it going to relate
to
yeah that's right I'm like this is what
happened last year and this is what I'd
like to happen for what I predict will
happen next year right so i'm going to
multiply this by now what shall I x 0
this percentage sales increase a
percentage is like say point point to
okay that would be twenty percent right
so I'm not going to multiply by point to
what am I going to x yeah 1.2 right so
I've got to say the percentage sales
increase sorry that's an S increase plus
1 tada okay so you can see how I was
looking for you to be careful in how you
actually created your formulas okay and
this will all be cells it rings it hard
for me to read but at least you can see
what they meet okay okay now they did
want you to take into account inflation
right so if you get this number what is
inflation inflation means as years pass
right the same amount of money can't buy
as much stuff right so it's like ah
let's see it do you guys remember what's
the cheapest fuel you ever remember from
the youngest age you were cuz right yeah
180 can you know a good cheaper than
that a hundred does anyone remember
prices below 100 ah let's just go I let
it reg you like yeah just unleaded 90 in
the 90s yeah okay I remember the
cheapest fuel that I actually remember
seeing when I was like sitting in the
sitting in the back and watching my dad
fill up i remember in the 70s okay
seventy cents a litre okay people like
wow you know from the prices of fuel
really going up you believe we're
playing seventy cents a litre I mean
what I didn't know any better so I was
like oh okay imagine what they would say
now right so back then and I think that
was about I think my memory must have
gone back say 20 years I was like I know
seven or eight or something like that
okay so in 20 years inflation has gone
from seventy cents a litre fuel to like
a dollar forty fuel so prices have as US
dollar fifty yeah I foot up for Donna 40
the other day but I had like special
batch of stuff
so the prices of objects has inflated
right so if i were to work out what the
difference is between how much i've sold
and how much that's really going to be
worth right after the price of things is
taken into account what am I going to
have to do well I'll take these total
sales and you could either multiply or
divide but it made probably more sense
to divide now what should I / now just
like this is a percentage sales
increased right I've got my inflation
room actually these are all percentages
I should have I should just put that ok
so the inflation rate right it's just
like the tax rate it's just like the
sales increase rate I have to divide by
1 plus so that's a plus lot of for the
inflation rate ok and every year the
inflation rate happens again and again
and again ok that's why prices increased
gradually right so you're actually going
to need to raise this thing to a power
and that's how you raise up out right at
that little hats in ok yeah so if you're
like oops right so these are the kinds
of things I was looking for right so you
would have raised it to subpar whatever
year you were like one year after this
year two years after this year three
years after this year that's all ok now
by the way you're like I didn't do any
of this that's why we're doing this
review now so the next time your will ok
so right to calculations out of 10 right
now that's going to be my sales what did
we say profit was proper was how much
you sold it for minus minus what costs
how much everything is actually costing
you right so I'm gonna have the goods
cost this is kind of nice because I'm
going to get three calculations here
that are all very similar I've got a
Goods costs and admin costs right what
was the other costs marketing
okay so how do I get all of these right
hmm now I know these as percentages
right so how do i convert that into it--
dollars I mean we convert that to
dollars any takers good now I percent of
total sense so I need the total sales in
here sorry total sales yes okay and then
i'm going to multiply it by let's see
here the percent that goods costs right
and in the presence that admin costs are
upset that marketing costs so those are
going to be my costs so percentage of
goods and it continues down via rates
the same its total sales times
percentage advan and this is total sales
times the percentage of marketing okay
so that's that's going to give me my
costs all together so I say let's say
total cost right is this Plus this Plus
this okay so that's the sum of now you
could just say this plus this for this
or you could use a sub function which is
kind of a bit need of its love everybody
so grids cost admin costs
and marketing costs or whatever sells
they refer to okay okay we're doing well
why do we work out sales and costs
because we wanted profits right yes good
so profit we said this right at the
beginning or pox head around it begins
right it's going to be a total sales
minus total costs okay yes so far so
good now I've got to do two things um to
this profit before I have my final aired
sell my final answer is going to be
accurate predictions of post tax profit
post tax profit okay so what am I gonna
have to do here I know what the tax rate
is ok and I'm going to get taxed on
whatever profit I've got ok so I'm going
to say tax is going to be well how much
did you go that's your profit and then
i'm going to multiply that by the tax
rate can you see how all the pieces
doing all that work early and say okay
here all the piece of the jigsaw i gotta
fit together it makes this so much
easier because you like oh well this is
left over I've got to use it eventually
right so there's my profit tons of tax
rate so this is my tax ok so now i can
say okay how much do i really come out
after the ATO nicked off with some of my
money ok so we would call that you've
got one of your life but net profit is a
good way to put it so that's profit
minus tax ok does that make sense now
how many equations is this count with me
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 ok now I said there
were 10 what am I missing because net
profit that sounds pretty good right
like I'm done I I I already have my
gross profit I just didn't call it that
good pickup but i have actually
calculated what am i missing hmm and
remember we were told you I petrol right
why are we talking about petrol it
inflates right and we took that into
account here right we say when you set
you know you make sales ok then it's
going to be its value will change based
on inflation guess what the same thing
is going to happen to your profits
you're like I made a million dollars you
know in 20 and 20 and 50 ok and then
someone's life dude in 2050 your million
dollars might even buy a bit back ok so
we're going to take into account well
you know it's like has anyone been to
one of those countries where it's like
you know you go to buy something yeah
and it's like yeah that'll be that'll be
fifteen million rupees or something
you're like what I don't know if 50
billion then someone's like yeah here's
a fiver you'll be fine ok so my net
profit right I'm gonna have to just
adjust that for inflation as well so in
their profit read inflation ok and to
adjust your inflation I do the same
thing that I did before I take the net
profit and then i divided divided by the
inflation rate plus 1 to the power of
what however many years we are in the
future ok so that the more years we've
gone the more inflation is had its
effect ok I suppose I should put
brackets around that okay all right now
exhale right that was the bulk of the
work you did really well if you stay
with me that long ok now how do you put
this all together into an actual
spreadsheet right now I think you sort
of had to decide for yourself should I
put years like two thousand fourteen
fifteen sixteen seventeen should I put
it across the top or as columns I should
have put them as rose ok I think you've
worked out better if you could do but
either is fine but I think you worked
out better if you went time across the
top ok so you know for example say 2000
13 or actually 2012 because that's in
the past so I know it okay so this is
his facts okay i'm going to have one
column for those then i'm going to have
all these predictions I've run out of
space you should have one more for five
years right now all of this stuff here I
put it in another color all of this
stuff here is calculations all those
calculations we just mention it up above
right all of this over here for all the
subsequent years okay you get the idea
right but what's the what's the data
that we actually know about each of the
things well it's going to be all of not
this stuff sorry all of this stuff here
right so I'm going to need to have just
said let's see here I'm going to have
total sales and then have sales with
inflation I'm going to have costs I'm
going to have profits all of the
calculations we just made they're all
going to go down here okay now you're
going to have to have somewhere for your
inputs right so you know maybe you want
to put all of your inputs down here
stuff like we already mentioned them
right tax rate inflation rate and so on
okay so maybe you just want to shut them
down here and all of your equations up
here you see if I can put it all on at
once can I do that I can zoom down right
yeah perfect there you go so all of your
inputs here are your tax rate inflation
rate for the percentages for the
different sales how much you think next
year your sales will increase that's all
down here and I will affect all of these
calculations all of this will be pulled
out from either calculations or the
previous year's database okay